Hãy mong hai tăng chính nè mùa nghiên chính trọng bố ngâm tại quảng trường và đình lịch sử,
chú tịch hồ chính mình thay mặt chính phủ lâm thời, chính trọng đặc bản tuyên ngôn đập lập,
khai sình nước Việt Nam xâm chủ cận hoa, này là nước cộng hoa xá hội chủ miếp Việt Nam.
Lần đầu tiên trong lịch sử, xân tập Việt Nam khiến ngàn khẩn định trước cùng xân đồng báo và toàn thế giới,
nước Việt Nam có quên rửa tự só và đập lập và sự thật đã thành mũ nước tự só đập lập.
Tự khoảng khách khiến liên ảy, nhưng xân Việt Nam chính đức trở thành công xân của một đánh nước nập lập,
mở khách khiến mởi trong lịch sử dân tộc. Nhưng ý nghĩa của ngày 12 thành chính,
không chỉ dừng lại trong biên sử dịch Nam, tuyên ngôn nập lập đã văn phòng, khơi sảy nhìn tiên và cô bố hành trở con tiên yêu tự sâu,
chính thắp thì giới.
Lần sau kè quan trọng măng giá trị lịch sử của Việt Nam và mang gồn giá trị tình tần rất lớn,
vui phòng trọng kích mạng trực kê dễ rộn từng dân sâm lập. Tuyên ngôn nập lập có vai trọng quan trọng,
bởi vì đã chỉ gà trị tình tối, nhưng giá trị vô cùng tò lớn, bây giờ,
làm thấy vào biệt lực phòng trọng kích mạng, xây dực và bổ xung quá trình xây dực nhé sau,
tức được phát triển bị tự la của trên loạn mà.
Chúng mắt đặt đẹp của tế, Việt Nam không chỉ là một đất sành đự đập lập,
mà không chỉ thành tâm tư sáng, một ngọn hải đang rất lối cho không trọng giải phòng dân tập ở YouTube.
Vì em Nam, si em phải phương phá, Việt Nam là một tấm gương diện liền về đấu tranh sải phòng dân tóc,
về tình thử đận kết cho tất cả nhân loại mà muốn có lập lập lập tự gió.
Thì mắt đầu nó phải chính xác của chúng tôi, chúng tôi tổng sây lấy Việt Nam là một vi giủ diện hệnh cho cuộc đấu tranh sải đấu lập tự gió.
Chúng tôi rất thử hảo khi có ngọt hạnh đăng điều vệnh,
với những vi giủ diện hảo YouTube's YouTube mình và những hình thử hỏi lấy nạo diện này của Việt Nam.
Bột gia đình để sự tên rình tố điều.
Việt Nam từ một đất nước điện chiếm tránh tạm phá, nêm tinh tế kịch quệ,
lạm phát của lúc lên tới hôm ấy chẳng hình chăm, Việt Nam đã phân lên nhóm tên các tuần nhập trù mình,
không ngừng thẳng lịch bị hẻ chiếm trường của tế,
nhớ cũng thành tự hôm này, tăng làm chung hình xin Việt Nam thêm tự hảo,
thêm chân trọng giá chỉ khi tiên liên của lập lập tự sơ.
Ngày mùng hai tăng chính, không chỉ là ngày đốc lập của Việt Nam,
mà còn lòng ngày đến những ngoại nếu về một rất tập đã kiên cử đứng lên,
cho thành biểu tự hợi trời y chỉ tự sòn và thách hợp hòa bị ủc tế dưới.